[Music]
do
[Music]
this
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
hello and welcome to our home for the
holidays honestly
i am so happy you've all joined me here
today and right now we're coming live
from my home in l.a and
because i'm live trust me
and it's the holidays christmas is
beckoning i will be on my best bloody
behavior okay let's be honest i know
it's been a crazy year but i just want
to say a big thank you to all of you
because we're just shy now of nearly 20
million subscribers on youtube
and that's from around the world uh
different ages from the age of six to
ninety six and
everywhere i travel they're always
saying you know we love these scrimmage
recipe and um can you show us again how
to cook more steaks so
a big thank you and
with that 20 million subscribers
it sort of relates to
you've watched this face nearly three
and a half billion times honestly i
couldn't be more grateful for the views
and i can't wait to show you more
exciting content across
2022 so big thank you um
let's be honest and let's take a moment
reflect over the last 18 months i've
been so impressed to how well you've all
been cooking and if there's one thing
this sort of locked down pandemic tough
times has made us appreciate how
important food is across the table and
the importance of breaking bread and
sharing stuff so
trust me i'll be watching your videos
very very closely so the holidays only
days away i'm guessing the majority of
you still haven't planned what to cook
well the good news is today i'm going to
help solve that problem
with my ultimate holiday meal and this
is quick
delicious but more importantly easy to
do so the menu first off we're going to
start off with an amazing pan-seared
scallop with a delicious butternut
squash puree and that's going to be
lifted with an amazing pomegranate slaw
so it's going to combine that sort of
earth and the sea and that fresh of the
slaw is going to be incredible then on
to the main um
rumors have it that the old turkey those
things are sparse okay they're there's a
little bit salt after so i've lined up a
chicken thigh and it's a delicious lemon
herb chicken thigh with a crispy bacon
gravy and it's this sort of go-to
perfect comfort
uh dish that when you see hits the table
i promise you everyone wants to dive in
there then we're going to move on to
some exciting sides because everyone
struggles cooking vegetables properly so
i'm going to show you an amazing way how
to elevate a leek
um and when i say elevate a leak i'm
talking about a braised leek um and then
i'm going to show you again how to do
some beautiful roasted vegetables all in
one pan
and then to lift it up um i'll show you
how to make a very simple delicious
salad that is stress-free but is a great
eye-opener at the table and then the
grand finale will be an amazing
stunning panna cotta
um
90 of this is all about the prep okay
and so if we get the prep right the
cooking becomes easy and as a chef i've
always been asked everywhere i go what
pans you use what knives you cut with
and i say it's all down to the personal
choice and so
um pans for me is like
it's like
driving a car and so hex clad and i've
been working together for the last two
years and developed these amazing pans
but more importantly i need to feel the
handle i need to feel comfortable the
non-stick element is amazing but it
retains the heat and you'll see across
this live cook that we're coming out of
the oven onto the table and these pans
are just
that good and
diverse and because we're live and you
know i love going live and let's be
honest every chef on the planet cooks
live every night in the restaurant so
you'll see proper cooking no editing and
just
just just some magic between you and i
and across this cook we'll be doing some
live questions and i know i've got uh
questions coming in from the outer
hebrides in scotland uh right down to
san diego um but we're here to cook and
i'm glad you're with me on this journey
and we're live okay promise not to screw
it up follow things carefully come in
with those questions and i just like to
show you
that i'm very lucky to be where i am
because of the talented team that are
alongside me not underneath me not on
top of me but
side by side and you think i'm on my own
but um
patrick would you just pan to the entire
team and just say hello
justin cello back little wave there you
go
nice jumper by the way justin mandel
beautiful
so we've been here since five o'clock
this morning setting this thing up and
like i said no editing is live and a big
thank you to youtube um for giving me
this opportunity to show you how to make
christmas a little less stressful
right um let's get on with the cooking
um chicken thighs first um why am i
using thighs um honestly
i prefer using thighs that i do with the
breast especially when you're braising
this thing okay
first off get the pan nice and hot okay
we want to get that heat up get that
cranking
i'm going to sear off the chicken first
and then give it a really nice color
that is really important okay and this
thigh meat is unique because
it can take a really good sear don't put
anything in the pan until you're ready
how many times i've watched people put
oil in the pan they go to use it it's
burnt so get everything ready first and
then
go into the pan lift
that chicken over we'll start off a
little bit of olive oil in there crank
up that amazing heat so this is a really
nice sort of
braised chicken thigh and the nice thing
about this is that you know even cold
the next day is delicious a couple
minutes in the oven but it retains
everything
okay
skin side down first
into the pan
hear that noise that crispiness
so get that sears beautifully we're
gonna put some color on the chicken
how many times you said it
yes no color no flavor
wash my hands
just in case the old uh
salmonella police are watching me i'm
not talking about salmonella the twins
let's go i'm talking about the
salmonella please hands nice and clean
right
get that chicken really nice and seared
i've seasoned the skin
i'm gonna season the side now with the
bone okay
now i'm gonna put a little touch of heat
in there that's the chili flake
and that is gonna help lift that amazing
flavor
now from there season at the top
i don't like adding flowers to thicken
things i like to cook the flour out
that's really important
just crank that heat up again
and you'll see
when this pan goes into the oven what
i'm talking about in terms of how it
comes out and onto the table sits on the
trivet and it's a beautiful beautiful
dish
now
i said you lemon with the chicken why
it's going to lift up that flavor and
it's going to make this sort of gravy
less rich and all we're going to do is
just top and tail the lemon
okay
and then stick that in
literally into quarters
now
i love this dish
and
we're using the thigh the drum is
equally delicious and the lemon just
missed the flavor
but before i turn that chicken take a
little tablespoon of flour
into a little sieve okay and just
lightly dust
the chicken with that flour i'll explain
why
this is going to help the base of the
gravy okay
and more importantly as we roast that
flour off it imparts an amazing flavor
and literally helps give the sauce a
little bit of a body which just lifts up
that nice richness
now
check one first
when you turn something in the pan don't
continue turning unless they're colored
okay so make sure that you've got cut on
them first before you turn them crank
the heat up because this side of chicken
we're going to turn to now it's cold so
it'll bring the temperature pan down so
over
over
now look at that color
beautiful
and now we're going to sort of
fry
that flour and that's going to make this
amazing
really good
rich gravy
this thing can be done in the morning
and then left in the evening and put
back in the oven for sort of 15-20
minutes to reheat it's just a it's an
easy dish and espresso in our household
with so many kids it's just sort of if
you get out of jail card and i know you
know everyone's stresses about that bird
the turkey etc chicken is a great
alternative especially across the
holidays and even if it's a sunday lunch
it's a great way of doing it
now in there
let's lift up a little bit of fragrance
okay
a touch of time just sit in there i like
keeping it whole it's easy to take out
what happens all these little buds come
off the stem flavor the chicken you just
take out the stalks big deal grows me
the same way okay a nice big stick of
rosemary
now
from there
i've got good color on the chicken okay
i'm gonna do now is take that chicken
out
and you can hear those herbs
crashing away so beautiful
from there
once that's out
keep the heat in the pan okay
i'll explain why now
look at that
that flavor is beautiful
okay in with my bacon
okay and this is where we start to build
up those amazing flavors
bacon goes in
useful
lemon bacon
amazing
onions in
now i've got a bit of heat in there with
that beautiful chili okay
when you get chance to cook chili flakes
so early on
they become less powerful and it sort of
brings the heat in a very mellow way
but look what's happening now is that
bacon but amazing flavor the lemon is
really sort of bring down that heat but
more importantly
with all that flavor from that chicken
in there
now
this is a beautiful
cider again it just lines up the flavor
it lays the pan with a touch of cider
literally
half a bottle
okay
and then from there
mix that in
and what we say deglaze it's a bit of a
chef thing all we're doing is just
washing the bottom of the pan
okay and what we're washing washing that
flavor that comes back up into
that amazing chicken
from there take a little touch of stock
okay i'm going to use chicken stock
because it's chicken you can use
vegetables if you wish but be stock a
little bit too heavy a little bit too
rich
so look
lift that up
now
bring that back up to the boil and then
from there put your chicken
skin side up
okay and literally sit that back in that
amazing flavor right
really important
now
here's the
here's the magic
lemon started to sort of disintegrate
what actually happens that lemon sort of
breaks down and gives a nice little sort
of bitter flavor to that chicken
bring the temperature back up which is
really important
i'm going to set a little touch of chili
on top so that skin gets even crispier
i'm going to get some more lemon
okay and zest
on top of that chicken
and so this is going to make it really
fragrant
and the reason why i haven't covered the
thighs in stock is because i want the
thighs to absorb all that stock
okay
the skins get nice and crispy
that bacon to render down
and we make this sort of nice lemony
herby
delicious gravy i have nightmares with
the word gravy because it's that sort of
stodge that looks like your granddad's
wallpaper paste from school so i want to
lighten things up with a gravy and make
it really exceptional
from there
a touch of seasoning on top what that
does it helps get rid of some of the
moisture from that chicken we've lost a
lot of seasoning because we're turning
it and tossing it around but i want that
skin to get nice and crispy we'll see
why in a minute
now
season on top and what happens now the
thigh absorbs all that stock the skin
gets nice and crispy and 20 minutes
later you got this succulent juicy thigh
delicious and it's crispy topping and
underneath this nice lemony herby gravy
right told you it wasn't that difficult
job one done in the oven we go with that
okay
high heat around sort of 320
330
now next i'm always asked um leeks you
know what we do is a
is it a leaking potato soup what else
can we do with leeks
so i'm going to show you how to do
something pretty stunning and elevate
these leaks they're going to be sort of
braised pan seared and then cooked with
a beautiful miso glaze and something
quite sweet about a leek and when you
add meat to it so such a mirin
it's mind-blowing it is absolutely
delicious
so over here please um richard patrick
just panned down
so these leaks they've been um peeled
the outer leaves have been discarded cut
in half and all i do is just dump them
in water
okay and that opens up all these little
flaps and it stops the sort of sand from
hiding in there and you sort of
vigorously push it down and that just
cleans your leak nothing worse than the
dirty leak at christmas let me tell you
pan nice and hot
i'm gonna get the uh olive oil in
because i want some rich texture to
these leeks
and when you think
how cheap these leaks are
you'll see the transformation this
flavor profile on a freaking leak okay
it's something that chefs use for a stop
we're gonna braise them and they are so
delicious so get that oil nice and hot
in we go with the leeks what i've done
here is i've kept the root on so that
holds the whole thing together
as it's braising if we took that off
they'll disintegrate and separate so
hold the route on
if it's clean it's edible okay once
that's cooked beautifully it literally
does
hold the whole thing together leaks into
the pan
okay roll them over
and just push them
together almost like
sort of sandwich them together
now from there once we start to get that
color on there
okay
leeks is a very hard vegetable to get
right so lightly seasoned
salt pepper
colour them nicely
okay
again from there a little touch of chili
flake you can lift that up
and then
watch once we start to get that color on
them turn them upside down
turn them back over and look at that
beautiful color
so good
now
we've got that flavor in there
from there
a little touch of stock
just a touch of stock
spray beautifully
in
keep the heat in the
pan and now in with a miso okay so i'll
just let this down with a touch of stock
and then
just spoon that over the side of the pan
and the miso is going to add some
texture it's going to sweeten things up
but such a lovely way of cooking leeks
and they're going to be like a fast
braise
so tasty
next from there i've got a little touch
of sweet soy okay that's going to enrich
in it and give a little touch of
saltiness to those leeks delicious
after that a little hint of some maple
and what that does it just helps
caramelize the sugar from the leeks and
then of course a tiny tiny amount of
sesame seed oil tiny
and then finally for some acid mirroring
okay it's like a nice
tablespoon of mirin
now look at the flavor in there
honestly
all i do next is get my garlic
and just
sip the garlic over the top of those
leeks bring that to the boil
okay
put a little touch
of butter in there
just in the side it's going to enrich
the amazing flavor of that braising and
like i said these leaks take at least 15
to 20 minutes in the oven but the flavor
of these things is off the charts
touch more stock so it's not too thick
and you're gauging this now okay
recipe's there as a base okay not to be
copied but as a base for you to elevate
bring that to the boil
and then into the oven
now
watch
chicken's getting nice and crispy
boiling away
and we'll put the oven
crank it up a little bit put the leeks
at the bottom of the oven so they sort
of help
beautifully browse
so good
turn that up
and then we are motoring
right good
well done
so
chicken's in
we're 20 minutes in chickens and leeks
are in um
vegetables we always worry about
so many vegs and the variety we know how
important veggie is so i'm going to show
you a really nice sort of cool way of
elevating those roasted vegetables um
really important
now from there i've got my onions my
turnips parsnips
just cut them in half
half again and then into quarters
everybody worries about the stem
if you cook them properly the actual
stem purees and so
sometimes we take off too much of the
stem the actual parsley overcooks so i
just like to take the tips off because
they burn
and then from there literally slice
these down
into half and then each one into a
quarter okay but the flavor is
incredible and the only way to do this
properly is to gauge
how long each veg takes okay so i've got
my parsnips
with them i'm gonna slice some beautiful
fresh ginger and that just lightens the
flavor of that
roasted vegetable finish
ginger when you roast ginger it's just
so delicious
so i've got my carrots my onions my
turnips and
my beautiful parsnips okay
now gauge it what's gonna take the
longest to cook honestly it's gonna be
the carrots they're gonna take the
longest so start off with them first
now oil in
get some really nice color on those
carrots
okay
these are beautiful rainbow carrots just
washed not even peeled
then from there i'll get my onions in
okay
sit them there
beautiful whole onions just slice into
quarters and then my turnips
and look
these turnips again just wash don't peel
them the flavor in that skin is
incredible
again touch more seasoning
beautifully roasted
some pepper
and then on this side of the pan
i'm going to go in
with my amazing parsnips
you know we're always worried about
serving vegetables separate i'm saying
look cook them independently bring them
together at the end so it's a great way
of serving a wonderful bowl of amazing
vegetables especially across the
holidays
okay
so carrots onions turnips parsnips and
then i'm going to just sprinkle
that fresh ginger
all over them
now
ginger in
beauty done touch more salt
okay and then from there
a little bit of chili flake in there
i've got the heat in the pan
and now i just want to get that
colored
beautiful
so
i don't like blanching a lot of
vegetables i like cooking them from raw
in order to really sort of
taste the flavor of those vegetables
really important
so
now we're going to go for the mix up
and start
literally
mixing them up
i said earlier 90 of the battle is when
we absolutely
get prepped properly and learn to
delegate coffee holidays give jobs out
to members of the family whether it's
chopping or peeling and so you can just
focus on purely the cooking
so
i love this pan because it's nice and
wide it's shallow sides and it's just
almost like a sort of modern version of
the wok for the vegetables it is
beautiful
now from there
i've got a little type of butter
in with my uh roasted veg
okay and that's going to cause a really
nice little
nut brown flavor they won't burn because
i started off in olive oil okay
butter
generously done
okay
and then from there
let that butter melt
now you could add
a couple of
sort of tablespoons of water i like to
put a little bit of stock in there
but look look at the flavor
and the thing about cooking vegetables
all at the same time just make sure
they're cut evenly okay
so from there
a little bit of my stock
around the outside
beautiful
so beautiful
and then from there i'm going to pop
them into the oven they're going to cook
down i'm going to absorb that stock that
butter that flavor and
just look at those colors
the colors are beautiful
into the oven we shall go
now
here we go
there's three main things already done
in a way that it's sort of become a
little bit less stressful and
i think for me the most important thing
is understanding the essence of that
prep i'll quickly show you my chicken
where we are
because we're live and there's no swap
outs
but just look
i've got a pattern to come
look at that that's bubbling down
that stock is reducing beauty the skins
get nice and crispy all those flavors
are permeating those thighs and is
absolutely lifting the flame this is
chicken thigh for god's sake they cost
55 pence each or a dollar and then
check out the leaks
these things are beautiful
so beautiful again
i can tell whether cooked or not when i
put my knife in there
and there's a little bit of resistance
okay you want that knife to sort of go
through like it's butter but when you
take these leeks out
sometimes i just have these these leaks
for tea dinner tea is what we were
growing up it's called tea and if i
grated some parmesan cheese on there and
grated them with the grill it's just the
most elegant way of ever eating a leek
right
good leaks in chicken in vegetables in
once you've got that done it's sort of
it it creates a lot more freedom because
you've got those main issues of that
party menu off your shoulders
so um i know we're live when we go and
get some um some questions now um we
have a
question there justin please
yes hello
oh hello hello kim
questions from
around the world right now we'll start
one with david from belgium david from
belgium david from belgium wants to know
how long does a turkey need to be in the
oven
uh david come on it depends how big your
bird is well first of all you know they
should be cooking minimum two and a half
to three hours i always say um
way out the bird um and then
devise the time according to the weight
but the secret of cooking a great turkey
is letting it rest for as long as it
cooks and more importantly
baste
you know those birds need basting and if
we don't sort of open up those legs at
the side and basting between those
thighs um you're going to have a raw
sort of thigh and an overcooked breast
so
base base base minimum should be two and
a half to three hours but i promise you
now if you let it rest and the secret
behind letting it rest is turning the
bird upside down halfway after you rest
it good question good luck by the way
uh char from the u.s wants to know how
can i make scrambled eggs more luxurious
for the morning after thanksgiving uh
for breakfast or brunch using last
night's ingredients ciao really you've
not watched youtube i think we have 40
million viewers now watching that
incredible uh gordon ramsay recipe for
scrambled eggs um
so
it's a big staple across a brunch i like
to make those eggs a little bit fluffy
finish them with things like smoked
salmon or any smoked fish in there it's
just beautiful but the secret behind any
great scrambled egg is put a tablespoon
of creme fration that stops the eggs
from overcooking but more importantly
absolutely
makes them light and fluffy okay so
yeah that's really important good
question um
let's see let's go to eddie who's asking
she i love a christmas dinner but i
still have some questions is it better
to put a dry rub on a turkey or a wet
brine
eddie eddie eddie it works both ways if
you've got the space to brine uh a
turkey then that's great uh really good
indeed
and so for me
the secret of a great turkey
is
on that rub
so when you're not brining here's the
tip
do that dry rub the night before and rub
all the skin all over with that
beautiful
combination of those spices and those
herbs and then on the morning when you
cook it a line
line underneath the skin with that
beautiful scented butter and that will
prevent that turkey from coming dry but
i always go brine if you can't brine it
then i promise you
seasoning and marinating your turkey the
night before so those herbs almost stain
the color of that skin line it with
butter underneath you'll have an amazing
turkey for holidays
uh i am human wants to know how do i
make my roasts more moist i've always
noticed that when i'm making my roast in
a crock pot it's always dry even after
adding broth wow wow
so
um dry rice nothing worse than that
any good roast needs to be
it needs to be based it and also it's
about the stock what kind of stock have
you got in there and i always say start
off with an intense heat
get that beautiful color on that uh
whether it's a tri-tip whether it's a
rolled sirloin whatever it may be but
get the color on it and then
shut down the heat and let it cook
slowly but as it's cooking i promise you
get a ladle of those juices and keep on
basting if you're short of juices at the
bottom of your tray just get some butter
and stick some butter on there if it's
coloring too fast get some foil and put
some foil on there and take it off for
the last 20 minutes to cook nothing
worse than a dry roast
uh mary from oklahoma wants to know what
are some good salvaging tips like say
your pie isn't setting but the crust is
already burned or your stuffing is too
soggy what would you do
mary mary mary um nothing worse than a
burnt crust um that's a really good
question when we make pies at sort of
christmas holidays we tend to make all
the beautiful ragu first and cook the
pie crust separately on a flat tray and
then depending on who you've got coming
around cut them out with cutters your
pie crust so you heat up that chicken
pot pie for instance and then garnish it
with pie crust
pie crust cooked can last three or four
days in a normal kitchen you just flat
it through the oven and so don't worry
too much about doing the perfect pie
crust cook the crust separate sometimes
and add it
to the pie at the end it worked
beautifully especially quite a very busy
time
um lily from the uk wants to know what
are your tips for the ultimate roasties
and what's the best way to use up
leftover turkey lily lily lily um really
good question so um
roast is you know
we've all got leftover roast potatoes in
the fridge okay and the big one for me
is to
get them nice and firm
and then to get a grater and grate them
okay and if you get this grater it's
almost like a sort of hash brown and you
grate them chop up some scallions or
spring onions or red onions and then fry
them and it makes this really nice
potato hash so do not waste those
leftover roast potatoes i promise you
grating them or even chopping them fine
and making this lovely sauteed hash
brown that with an egg on top
a little devil of hp sauce honestly uh
that for me is perfect leftover turkey
every year we get asked the same
question um you can't beat a beautiful
turkey noodle soup
and use that carcass to get a great
stock shred all that meat from there and
then drop in things like tiny little
bits of orzo fresh vegetables in there
and so you've got this amazing soup
because sometimes we get a little bit
overwhelmed we just want a nice big bowl
of turkey broth soup that is a great way
of utilizing it i'm fed up with everyone
saying curries and do this to that
you cannot beat a turkey broth noodle
soup perfect right last question no
justin don't be tight it's christmas i
know come on susan
susan from new york times are you on a
date tonight i'm not definitely not um
susan from new york wants to know why
are you taking my son away for three
thanksgivings in a row
that's unfair mrs mandel um we're off to
patagonia we're going to this
extraordinary uh
part uh of south america i didn't
realize it fell on thanksgiving um but
hear me out i promise you he's got you
the biggest present he's ever bought in
his entire life he's trying his eyes out
he's asking for discounts but
he's coming back and i promise you now
he's got some sweet treats for you um
and uh i'll bring him back in one piece
thank you for that really
it's the holidays i have to ask right
thank you happy hanukkah happy hanukkah
thank you happy holidays happy hanukkah
uh right uh back it's the most important
part the cooking uh butternut squash
okay this puree is so delicious you're
having three amazing girls they go
veggie from time to time vegan from time
to time or they just have this beautiful
butternut squash uh soup so we cut the
squash in half we season it
we bake it in the oven for 35 40 minutes
and then we scrape it into a pan
blitz it into a puree and it comes down
to this amazing
wonderful incredible puree this can
transform into an amazing soup for us at
christmas or it can be added as an
amazing vegetable but it's just such a
lovely thing to have done across the
holidays a butternut squash puree so
diverse
now i just want to show you one more
thing
i get these leaks out okay and then
i'm going to start with amazing scallops
have a look at these leaks
honestly
this
is incredible
because the flavor
inside these is beautiful it's going to
want to make you run down to the shop
and
leeks
just look how soft
and delicious they are when you pick
these up
honestly they are so
freaking delicious it's just a great way
of eating a very
humble
cheap vegetable beautiful
right check out my chicken that's 25
minutes in there still not done
but getting nice and crispy really
crispy right scallops as you know
i love this dish because it's quite
luxury at christmas or around the
holidays so it's a special treat the
secret is in the cooking i've done it
many times so i'm gonna do it again
today because it's quite magical for me
i'm cooking a skull up beautifully um
hand dyed scallops i've taken them out
the shell they're off they're sort of
coral we save that for a little bit of
stock
but the sheen on these things are just
beautiful a little secret dry them
between a towel overnight takes out that
moisture therefore we get a nice color
on them
i call that the fat side the shiny side
that's the top of the shell that's the
bottom it's the top that goes into the
pan when we go at twelve o'clock one
o'clock two o'clock three o'clock four
o'clock so we go around in a clockwork
formation so as you know to come back to
the top
to turn the first one so they're
perfectly cooked and i'm quite stickled
for cooking these things and
many times i've eaten them in
restaurants they've tasted like the
inside of a freaking golf ball so i'm
going to show you how to cook these
things beautifully and as an appetizer a
starter or even as a main course it goes
so well the garnish for that
i've got um
some cabbage
and i've turned this into a beautiful
little uh slaw red cabbage uh
white cabbage and then i've got some
pomegranate hazelnuts and a little bit
of a amazing quince
beautiful quinn vinaigrette it's very
tart it's acidic and it goes well with
the sweetness of those scallops okay
first off um let's get the pan nice and
hot for the scholars okay
now
get that heat up nice and high
okay the secret here is 90 seconds in
the seasoning 90 seconds in the pan a
nice season first
okay
and then literally scallops go in
i like to use little amount of salt rock
salt is so much better than the fine
salt pine salt burns the rock salt sort
of helps to crust the scallops and it
does taste so good but it's such an easy
dish
once all the guests have sat i like to
think of this starter as something can
be done and then literally step away
from the table
slaw done scott's roasted sure done
serve
and then let them dive in and understand
how much exciting flavor is going on
there okay pan
nice and hot okay trust me it's gonna be
worth it scallops in
first okay
let's start off like i said
down
12 o'clock in one o'clock
gas is getting a little bit too high so
i'll come off the heat
okay just come off the heat nothing
wrong with that at all it's columns in
now only cooking them once okay so be
very smart i don't panic about a hot pan
just take it off the heat don't throw
anything in there don't douse it down
just literally
take it off the heat
and
the ice coldness of those scallops okay
will cool down the pan instantly then we
put it back onto the heat now we've got
that beautiful
sear going on 12 o'clock all the way
around
whilst they're cooking
with my salad
um
dress it nicely okay
when you dress salads less is more in
terms of the vinaigrette okay because
that acidity kills the cellar which
makes it watery so be very smart how you
dress salads less is more okay
from there
we'll sprinkle my beautiful pomegranate
seeds over
some chopped roasted hazelnuts
okay and then just a little touch
of lemon
lemon zest again i'm a stickler for
lemon zest because it's free every lemon
and lime and orange there's so much less
there use it to liven things up okay
that's the garnish ready
now have a look at these scallops okay
i'm gonna bring them over here
a little bit
so i can just show you when we turn
these things i go to 12 o'clock
and turn them over twelve one
two
three
four
five six and seven look at the color on
those
back onto the heat
really important now colors there
keep that momentum up okay really
important
from there
take your lemon i've taken the zest
we should never throw a lemon in the bin
or the trash unless we zested it okay
i've got some beautiful dried
cranberries going into the slaw and then
to elevate this get a nice bunch of
fresh mint
and just roughly chop that okay
lift that up
and give it a chop but chop it once okay
i want the freshness in the slaw don't
over chop your herbs i want that flavor
in that slaw okay
beautiful now
30 seconds those colors are going to
come out
lemon
sits on top of the scallop a little
douse
just a touch
and then literally 10 seconds before
those scallops come out this is where my
butter goes in
okay
but it goes in
and this is where it turns into like a
benoisette they've got a really nice
nutty brown flavor
and that's going to mar
and match the flavor the hazelnut in
that beautiful
incredible salad
okay
beautiful
now touch them
and they should be a little bit
resistant just like taking your pulse
justin take your full skip give it a
pulse
take it take it how soft is it tell me
i'll buy you one for christmas okay
there you go scallops out
okay i'm going to go around clockwise
like i said to put them in the pan so
they're all cooked evenly
so the last one to take out is the last
one i've put in the pan really important
i know that sounds a little bit petty
but for me it's so important
season that over the top
now let them sit there for 30 seconds
okay
oh my goodness and this is where we
start to lift these things now as it
hits the table
um how do i go on there okay
so with my puree
first off
let's start off with
a nice dollop of scallop from there
one generous one is puree this flavor
the combination is incredible
i cannot tell you and as a sort of
little appetizer you know one nice
beautiful scallop
it is just so tasty
again when we sit these things on the
plate the round part of the scallop goes
to the round part of the plate so that
just sits on there nicely round
around
generously the color is exceptional the
smell without butter in the end is just
beautiful so sit them on there okay
and then from there get your
slaw
okay and just lift that
nicely i said you've dressed it lightly
okay and i'm going to do now is just
drop a little touch of slaw
in the middle
of those scallops and the puree and you
sort of scrape that off with the mint
and the puree and it's just so luscious
clean and fresh
and then i'm a stickler for heights i
just like a little bit of hype on the
plate
and then finally
from there
get my lemon
and just sit down there if that doesn't
scream holidays festive party i don't
know what will a little touch of that
quince vinaigrette okay
and let that sit and run into the puree
when you start tasting that butternut
squash puree with that incredible quince
vinaigrette and the roasted scallop it
is so tasty
and there's the beautiful scallops
so my leeks
by scallops
and
next
you can see it all come together now
right it's all happening my vegetables
oh my goodness me
i want to test
and just glaze them over
and look at them
again just check them go into the turnip
first knife is just running right
through
passing it
done
right through soft and elegant and the
nice thing about that
now that i've got that beautiful glaze
on there because everything's reduced
down i get my fresh herbs
i'm going to throw that over there
okay and then literally give them a
little toss
and just let them sit there with those
fresh herbs on top that's a beautiful
way a stunning way of cooking fresh
vegetables
scallops
oh my goodness me wait do you see the
chicken it is ridiculous
so beautiful
and we are
not quite crispy yet
but it's gonna get there three or four
minutes
so scallops done vegetables roasted
leeks elevated into the premier league
salad again
just having that amazing sort of connect
with my girls in terms of how important
their eating habits are and trying to
you know just make them feel at ease
with eating an amazing salad and i love
freshen things up so i always take a
little box grater i get an apple
a beautiful apple
and i grate
just great i get the apples out the
freezer
okay and i sort of just grate this thing
literally to order as they sit down
okay
and then from there look
blue cheese um
i freeze this and it helps crumble over
the salad beautifully
bang that down
when you see fresh grated apple over a
salad it's just so
beautiful it's like a little hidden gem
and it gives that nice little fresh kick
to a salad this is a little baby gem
salad that i've just washed and cleaned
and made sure that it's nice and crisp
in the fridge and now we dress it okay
less is more
first off
just get your spoon
and just pick
tiny little bits
of that blue cheese and because it's
frozen you get these tiny little
bits
there's nothing worse than a big lump of
ice cold blue cheese in your mouth
so just any more questions please not
from your mum please
i've got a question for you
[Music]
no no no no hold on hold on are you on a
date tonight
okay okay okay okay
um
no i'm just because of a few viewers in
the outer hebrides in scotland that are
young free and single would love you to
come over and replicate this food and
cook an amazing dinner yeah
unfortunately we're in l.a i don't think
i can get over this evening stop being a
snob where's the wheel there's a way
there's no supersonic flights yet ever
seen braveheart yes there you go come on
willie wallace you've got this
salad
back to dressing this thing lightly
don't dress it too early okay dress
until you're gonna kill the salad so i
just like to drizzle this vinaigrette
and we've got a little bit of persimmon
here now so i'm getting very festive but
just look if you have a dresser salad
honestly it's gonna look somewhat
weighted down and it's just gonna look
sort of soggy keep it crisp dress
lightly
and then it's festive i've got some
beautiful roasted walnuts okay
beautiful roasted walnuts and then
finally a little bit of a
there's a little bit of sort of ramsay
trick it's just a red wine shallot sort
of crispy delicious amazing
onion on top of that okay
now
from there that is a salad i'm telling
you now that is the ultimate salad so
so look at me let's recap we've got the
scallops roasted vegetables braised
leeks a beautiful salad and then
i'm gonna bring out the chicken i can't
tell you how excited i am i know haley's
behind the team are here but there's no
swap outs this is live and it just goes
to show you get this thing done
beautifully you ready
justin you ready
you should be running with all the
ingredients to scotland on this and cook
oh my goodness
look at that
come on
now you can't even identify any flour in
there okay you got that beautiful bacon
lemon onion gravy you've got this crisp
amazing
hear that
it's the sound of justin brushing his
teeth in the morning
that is crisp
that is crispier than his wife runs on
his first date on tinder i'm telling you
that is the way to cook a perfect
chicken
now we all have a little bit of sweet
tooth and we like to indulge so i kept
this very simple and i've done an
amazing panna cotta it's a bit of a show
stopper as you know it's beautiful
vanilla cream and milk how do you set
this thing i use very little gelatin
sometimes you use a caramel to set my
beautiful harry potter's in but
something can be done the day before and
brought out and just finished at the
table so here we go
right
thanks honey
so these beautiful
little
amazing nuggets
so
first of all
they should just wobble beautifully the
perfect texture and so
don't over set them because you want
that amazing flavor going on inside and
that's just a creamy vanilla infused
set custard is delicious i've got a
little touch
of a pomegranate production and that's
just going to sit on top and just pour
them over don't go crazy okay and let it
let it let it sort of just drizzle out
oh my goodness me and
let it spread beautifully okay
and then from there
it'll form this beautiful little film
across that sort of seals the deal i've
got a naughty drip that irritates me and
then
finally some beautiful little shaved
chocolate okay i like the sort of dark
chocolate milk chocolate it's beautiful
white chocolate is lovely and then for
that crunch
just a little
pomegranate on top and when you get
these
blocks
like this
you know the easiest way to get them
really nice is freeze it and then get
your knife and literally
just pull
and pull the knife towards you very
carefully stop halfway
and then literally look got these
amazing little shards
that just go on there
okay
and that is a beautiful way one more
again nice and carefully flat knife down
and then look
at these beautiful little shards no need
to temper chocolate the long way around
just on top
and there we have
a beautiful
stunning dessert
that i know justin mandel is now packing
his bags and on his way to the highlands
in hope that he cooks a delicious dinner
but hopefully his mum stops nagging me
that hopefully gets a serious
relationship across 2022
and there you go a perfect holiday meal
just take a look how beautiful this is
and i know if you follow the
instructions and just get inspired about
what we've just done
um you can recreate this okay i promise
you
90 of the battle is in the prep good
luck to you all i'd like to say a big
thank you across the planet for tuning
in today because i love this kind of
stuff okay and the comments coming in
honestly justin's not going to be lonely
at christmas
i can't wait to see your dishes take me
in when you get a chance to cook them
and who knows i may even react to some
of them and you know those reactions for
me are like you know
it's it makes my day a big thank you to
the amazing team here that helped put me
where i am today but most importantly
from myself and the entire ramsey family
and even oscar who even at the weekend
was standing up at the window and
looking for father christmas six weeks
out be here yourself young man have a
very safe and incredible holiday take
care and lots of love
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you